what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with the Hellfire Gala
specifically the resurrection of Miss
Marvel as a mutant and the ending of
this story is crazy so for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with the
Hellfire gala this is a comic of one
shot that Marvel releases every year and
usually it's a change in the X-Men
roster the old team is replaced with a
new team in this instance we're focusing
on Kamala Khan in the beginning and then
transitioning from there so of course
right off the bat she's basically
resurrected by Xavier and the five and
she's told in no uncertain terms that
she's a mutant now anybody who's been
reading Marvel Comics for any measure of
time is going to ask the question yeah
but I thought she wasn't inhuman how is
it that she's a mutant that gets
reconciled and then the deadly nature of
Terror Genesis foreign humans with
regards to mutants that gets dealt with
as well but for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with Resurrection when it
comes to the X-Men and Marvel Comics you
have what are called the five these are
five mutants known as Tempest Proteus
Hope Summers the egg and elixir between
their powers they basically have the
ability to resurrect people clone people
if you want to call it that use reality
warping to imbue them with whatever
modifications they may need to instill
whatever Powers they may need and then
because mutants minds are routinely
backed up which is really done
automatically memories that they had up
until the moment they died are placed
inside their bodies so this is the
reason why especially when it comes to
reality warping that like Wolverine for
example can die and then come back but
instead of simply just coming back with
bone claws he comes back with adamantium
reality warping is what allows that to
happen that's actually the power of
Proteus he can only do it in a localized
space but still the thing about Miss
Marvel's response here is that it's kind
of adorable right it's one of these
things where she's like okay this is
weird uh so like where are my parents at
like do they know that I'm dead do they
know that I died and like I've come back
to life like what in the world's going
on one of the fun funny things about
this is when she asked like how did I
die it's just kind of dismissed and
rightfully so because in Marvel Comics
she died in what is quite possibly one
of the most lazily written deaths in the
history of the comic book industry so
it's cool that they just kind of gloss
over it and ignore it but because we're
still talking about a shifting roster of
the X-Men the Juggernaut is actually
told by Jean Gray you should submit your
name for candidacy to become a new
member of the X-Men team now we'll talk
about how this whole process is
undertaken in terms of being chosen but
the Hellfire Gala is a big deal anyone
who's anyone is invited to become a part
of this Avengers X-Men the Fantastic
Four if they choose to appear although
as I understand it the Fantastic Four
and the X-Men are kind of on bad terms
ever since Franklin Richards lost his
powers but the thing about this is that
Miss Marvel looks amazing and like this
whole outfit this whole get up that she
has going on but the big thing that's
really addressed here by way of Marvel
is is the discrepancy between the
inhuman Gene and the mutant Gene now
this is something that people are either
going to love or they're going to hate
there's not going to be anybody in the
middle here so historically speaking in
Marvel Comics and this actually goes all
the way back to the son of X in the
aftermath of House of M when Quicksilver
tried to use Terra Genesis to give
mutants their powers back one of the
things we learned is that Terra Genesis
which is the process whereby in humans
end up gaining their powers that's
deadly to mutants so under normal
circumstances Miss Marvel should
basically be dead if she had a mutant
Gene and then she encountered Terra
Genesis it should have killed her on the
spot such as it is the response of
Xavier is that your mutant Gene simply
hadn't activated at that point in time
and instead it seems like whatever Gene
you did have was suppressed by your
inhuman abilities is it lazy writing
absolutely but the fact remains she is
now mutant and that explains how she
survived so on to the main point here
right like the absolute Insanity that
leads into the fall of X and what is
basically the end of the X-Men in Marvel
Comics so the big thing that goes on is
that when it comes to the the gala
itself you kind of get a little bit of
an introduction to newer characters one
of these is a guy named Wen now this guy
is incredibly mysterious we don't know
anything about him the only thing we
know is that he has a role to play in
Marvel's upcoming God storyline in
November when they're going to be
reworking the entirety of The Godly
Pantheon it's going to be written by
Jonathan Hickman my favorite writer ever
the story is going to be dope but wind's
very mysterious and in fact his
conversation with Ileana Rasputin also
known as magic who's actually another
magic wielder in Marvel Comics it's
really confined to him asking is it true
that when you guys set up this whole
island Magneto invited a whole bunch of
humans and then told them they have new
Gods now and she's like yes it was and
he's like that's dope but in the midst
of all this things pop off for the
Avengers and so the Avengers leave and
then a portion of the X-Men leave which
includes Scarlet Witch Rogue and so on
the reason why this happens is because
in Marvel Comics what you have right now
is something called the unity Squad that
was a concept that was originally
introduced in Marvel Comics and the
aftermath of Avengers vs X-Men when the
two groups fought against each other but
the unity Squad is basically one part
Avenger one part X-Men it's a pretty
cool team and it's a dope concept it's
one of my favorite things to ever come
out of Marvel but once everybody who's
part of the unity Squad effectively
takes off Jean Gray officially calls
into play the voting of the new X-Men
now the way this works and it's been
this way ever since the first Hellfire
Gala the telepaths read the minds of
everybody in attendance and what they do
is they vote on who the new X-Men should
be and whoever gets the most votes those
five or six people they become the new
team members in this instance we get
Talon who is basically x23 Laura Kinney
just operating by a different name can
involve Sam Guthrie who quite literally
shoots fire out of his backside and just
travels in a forward Direction it sounds
silly his character's dope sync who is
crazy overpowered this guy has the
ability to duplicate the powers of
anybody he's next to and there's
seemingly no upper limit right you've
got Prodigy I don't remember anything
about this guy frenzy who's an old
school villain in Marvel Comics but
she's kind of like a Luke Cage character
with indestructible skin but she's also
super strong dazzler who has the ability
to admit bright light she doesn't matter
Jubilee who's actually one of the most
powerful beings in Marvel but they just
never done anything with her and the
final member of the X-Men team of the
new team is Juggernaut Kane Marco which
is dope now where everybody's
celebrating this moment where the new
team is chosen they all get attacked by
Nimrod which is the worst possible
situation that could unfold for them and
the reason why is because for those of
you who are unfamiliar with Nimrod this
dude is a sentinel and this dude is a
Hoss because unlike any normal Sentinel
out there that's just a giant robot and
blasts the X-men with energy coming out
of his hands Nimrod is a sentinel that
was designed for the purpose of
analyzing the powers of any and all
mutants or even super powered beings
that it comes across and then
immediately adapting and overcoming
those Powers as well as calculating what
their weaknesses are and using those
weaknesses against them a perfect
example of this is with all this
pandemonium unfolding Ice Man Bobby
Drake jumps in now Bobby Drake is an
Omega Level mutant this guy has the
ability to freeze the core of the earth
and kill all life on the planet if he
wanted to this guy gets dominated I mean
it's not even close in fact the attack
of nimrod is designed in such a way to
where it basically neutralizes the
powers of Iceman and quite literally
melts him and that's the goal that
they're striving for is why Nimrod was
sent in first take out the Omega Level
mutants as fast as you possibly can and
so in response to this Jean Gray
basically fastball specials Juggernaut
which essentially means that she uses
her powers and just throws him directly
at Nimrod now a fight between Juggernaut
and Nimrod is something that we've never
seen before because remember Juggernaut
is not truly a mutant he's actually just
a guy who possesses What's called the
Crimson Gem of sidorak basically a gem
that grants him power from an other
dimensional being of immense power right
sidorak is crazy overpowered and so
Juggernaut being part of the team is
cool but fighting Nimrod that's the real
question here because other guys like
sync do what they can when they can and
where they can but while Juggernaut is
out there dealing with Nimrod which
we'll talk about here in a second you
basically have Dr stasis and Karima who
step in now Karima we haven't seen for a
long long time she's was called an Omega
in effect she's an answer to the
question what happens when you take a
person and blend them with Sentinel
technology and that's essentially what
she is she's pretty powerful in her own
right is she a character who's so op
that she's broken no but she is wildly
capable but the bigger thing about this
is that Dr stasis who's basically a
clone of the villain Mr Sinister and
there's actually four of them that are
still running around at the moment you
got orbit Stellaris Dr stasis mother
righteous and then the main Sinister
himself that what had been going on
behind the scenes while all the X-Men
were doing their stuff that what Dr
stasis had been doing was finding a way
to hack the krakowan gates that the
gates of krakowa are the only way in or
out of the island and you can plant a
gate anywhere so they're literally their
stories were like the accident of Planet
a gate tukurakoa on the other side of
the universe and you can just walk
through your gate and end up on Earth
but the other thing that he'd been doing
here is that while the X-Men initially
made their kind of rise to prominence by
way of offering Humanity these kind of
medicines that would extend their life
or would cure any kind of mental illness
or disease that what Dr stasis had been
doing was actually modifying those
medicines and what it did is it
effectively created a kill switch that
at any point in time he can flip a kind
of psychic switch and it'll kill every
single person on Earth who's consumed
the medicines of the X-Men now the
reason why this is such a huge deal is
because if he does that the entirety of
humanity is going to point the finger at
the X-Men population and say you've
killed every human here and then it's on
like Donkey Kong right full-scale war
and as we know from house and powers of
X the event that really kind of kicked
off the current ERA of the X-Men any war
that takes place between humanity and
the mutant population will ultimately
lead to the death of the mutant
population their complete and utter
destruction and so by virtue of being
able to hack these Gates what it does is
it allows the forces of Dr stasis and
really the organization he works for
called orcas to just come pouring in
orcas is kind of a combination of
different groups Advanced idea mechanics
Hydra Shield agents who are disgruntled
so on and so forth probably a few
Karen's here and there but they're all
basically anti-mutant and they're
constantly working to destroy the
mutants so this is kind of like their
best chance to launch their attack and
bring everything to an end what you also
end up seeing here is Iron Man's X-Men
Buster armor it's not something Iron Man
intended to create but it is all
developed through Stark Tech so it is
awesome to see these just like Iron Man
Sentinels running through and
effectively annihilating most of the
X-Men but what I hope you're realizing
here is this is a full scale attack
against the X-Men population on Earth
the mutant nation of krakowa and it's
not as though these guys are like
holding their own and they're doing well
miss Marvel's just kind of like I mean I
have no idea what to do you know you
know but like literally the whole thing
is just them getting crushed not only
that when you jump to the fight between
Juggernaut and Nimrod normally
Juggernaut would hold his own again it's
like 99 of any Force that's out there
one of the things that I don't think
we've ever seen which I would love to
see is a fight between Juggernaut and
apocalypse there is a story where
Juggernaut fights the Hulk and that
story is amazing but one of the crazy
things here is Nimrod gets the upper
hand on Kane Marco and he takes him out
and so in this moment what ends up
happening is Jean Gray stops everything
and the reason why is because Gene ever
since the days of the dark Phoenix Saga
in Marvel Comics has historically been
one of the most powerful telepaths on
the face of the planet now to provide a
little bit of context here depending on
what story you're reading in Marvel Jean
Gray's power and where she resides in
this kind of hierarchy of telepaths will
change but within the confines of this
story her power is of such a degree that
she's able to telekinetically freeze
everybody who's here and then use her
telepathy to basically start overriding
their minds and she literally tells
everybody here for all those individuals
who are on the side of the X-Men human
non-mutant alike you will be allowed to
stay here we'll get all this sorted out
we apologize for the inconvenience for
all of you who came here and intend to
inflict harm on us I'm going to give you
the choice to walk away willingly if you
don't I will destroy your minds inside
your own head you'll literally be
operating as a two-year-old for the rest
of your existence in that moment Dr
stasis makes the call and says it's now
or never friend and Jean Gray gets
stabbed in the back and basically starts
to die and the person who did it is
Maura X Mora McTaggart now lest we
forget in Marvel Comics and it's very
easy to forget this because it's been a
while since it's been discussed Maura
McTaggart was the one that basically
initiated this whole crookin era the
coming together of the mutant population
and all that kind of stuff but she did
it because she came to the realization
that ultimately the continued existence
of the mutant population would lead to
their destruction at the hands of
humanity so the only a way to prevent
the destruction of the mutant population
is to slowly phase them out every time a
mutant is resurrected one of them or a
handful of them would lose their mutant
Gene and over time she would reduce the
entirety of mutants down to zero But
ultimately her scheme was discovered she
was ousted from the entirety of the
X-Men landscape and she's just kind of
been working with orcas ever since but
she's got a vendetta here but the
presumed death of Jean Gray is enough to
light a spark and the remainder of the
mutant population and realizing that
Mora seizes Charles Xavier puts a knife
to his throat and says if anybody moves
the old man gets it and so they all
basically stop they all kind of freeze
in place and the funny thing about this
is that Xavier effectively surrenders
but he just kind of gives up now it's
not one of these things where he just
sort of sacrifices his life because it
doesn't really matter it's one of these
where he's doing it to preserve the
lives of all the other mutants that are
here because as long as this conflict
keeps going the number of me students
who have died that will just increase
over and over and over again now as an
aside some of you guys may be asking
where's Magneto in all of this remember
Magneto died during Judgment Day and he
destroyed the only way in which he could
be resurrected so his character has been
gone for quite some time so that's why
you really just don't see him here not
only that what Jean Gray does is she
telepathically communicates with
Firestar and then effectively tells her
I have slightly modified the memories of
Dr stasis kind of tapping into the back
of his own mind by essentially tricking
him into believing that you've been
working for him this entire time and
feeding him information about the X-Men
of course you haven't actually done that
but what it's going to do is it's going
to allow you to essentially stow away as
part of Dr stasis forces no one's any
the wiser to the fact that I have
planted memories that don't exist in
order to make that happen and you can
try to find a way to destroy them from
the inside out but understand this is
Jean Gray acting psychically she's got
moments before she's basically dead and
so what Xavier is told by Mora and
really just by Dr stasis is you are
going to instruct every mutant here
using your telepathy to walk through the
cocoan gates and they are going to leave
Earth permanently now remember the
secondary kind of backup safe haven for
mutants on Earth is Mars and that's
exactly where they're supposed to be
going to but the statement of Dr stasis
is very simple he says here's the way
things are going to work you're going to
leave Earth you're going to walk away
from this place if one mutant shows up
on Earth again we kill a human if a
second mutant shows up we kill 10 if a
third shows up we kill a hundred and
we'll keep multiplying that number by 10
and we will point the finger at you
every single time and even though
Humanity will become aware of the fact
that you are on Mars have no Illusions
Humanity will develop Interstellar
travel for no other reason than to find
and kill you the Vendetta will be that
strong now one of the things that Xavier
had done as each mutant was being
resurrected is he instilled in them a
kind of psychic block which is why you
see them uttering the words resist
because what it does is it allows them
to resist any telepathic attack from
anybody which includes Xavier because
during the X-Force story at least the
first X4 story arc that we got at the
beginning of this krakowan era there was
a strike on krakowa and Xavier was
killed they ultimately resurrected him
but that's when Xavier came to the
realization I am not Untouchable a time
will come when somebody could
potentially invade percoa and force me
to use my power for nefarious purposes
and if that happens there needs to be
safeguards in place I.E giving a means
to every mutant on krakowa that can
allow them to override these telepathic
attacks from anybody anywhere and so for
those mutants who don't walk through the
gates and who are capable of resisting
they actually stand fast but what's so
funny about this is a teleporter whisks
them away now the reason why this
matters is because no one would know
where they went to they would just
disappear off somewhere when you have Dr
orcas and Moira who are telling all the
X-Men to go to Mars it puts them in a
location where they can easily be
monitored where they can easily be
tracked right it's apparent telling
their child go to your room as opposed
to a parent telling their child go away
and then who knows where they end up and
so with some of these exceedingly
powerful mutants really Emma Frost being
one of the most powerful of them with
them just kind of whisking away and
disappearing there's no telling where
they've gone to which now makes them an
extremely capable Rebel Force now what's
so wild about this is that in the midst
of this whole thing you have Nimrod who
shows back up with Juggernaut after
having absolutely thrashed this guy and
basically killed him which is kind of
nuts to see that Nimrod killed the
Juggernaut that's something I never
thought I would ever see in Marvel
Comics it's wild as Dr stasis Nimrod and
all these guys have this kind of
conversation that now they've
successfully taken over the mutant
nation of percoa any large influx of
mutants are effectively out of their
hair there's like 250 000 of them who
are all basically on Mars now with the
exception of a small contingent who were
teleported away you jump to Emma Frost
and her forces when they try to pass
through the gate it doesn't work there's
no way for them to get through there's
no way for them to get back to where
they were before and so jumping back to
stasis and these guys they kind of
betray their word that where they
promised they would not kill humans if
the mutants chose to leave Earth they do
exactly that they eradicate every single
mutant that's present on top of that
Nora makes her move to kill Professor
Xavier it's very reminiscent of like
Avengers versus X-men when Cyclops
killed Professor Xavier but what's crazy
here is that before that can happen
Rogue shows up and then immediately
frees Xavier rips Moira in half and then
flies off now where she's saving Xavier
she's taking him to a safe location his
response is no you have to take me back
to the island and where she says what in
the world are you talking about his
response is you don't understand all
those mutants that I have sent to arako
they're dead they're gone there's no way
to save them and when her response is
what in the world are you talking about
there was a quarter of a million of them
his response is no they're all dead and
gone now the reason for this while it's
not explicitly shown here largely seems
to be the Genesis War that's taking
place on Mars the mutants don't know
about that they don't know the Genesis
war is taking place out there so Xavier
unwittingly sent all these mutants
basically Into The Killing Fields
completely and totally none the wiser to
the fact that he was doing that and so
he literally tells Rogue get out of here
get out of here as fast as you possibly
can unite whatever forces you can
possibly unite and try to find a way to
avenge the X-Men but understand this is
the entirety of the mutant population
running on a shoestring they've been
overpowered crushed and they're just
fleeing for their lives so God only
knows what happens but with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end if you want to get caught up with
everything going on with the X-Men make
sure you click this video that will give
you all the important details that you
need and I will catch you all later
peace